sie war lange erwartet heute vollziehen
und stadt die reise des bundeskanzlers
in die ukraine gemeinsam mit frankreichs
präsident mag italiens regierungschefs
draghi und rumäniens präsident johannes
europa in kiew gut vertreten mit einer
klaren botschaft aller vier politiker
die ukraine soll zur eu gehören und den
status als beitrittskandidat erhalten
scholz sprach lange mit präsident
selensky und er sah sich auch die
kriegsschäden im kiefer vor ort
irgendwann wird er jetzt mit anderen
augen auf diesen krieg schauen wird
diese reise die ukraine politik
deutschlands verändern und werden
vielleicht doch mehr waffen geliefert
werden hoffnung in der ukraine kiew
unser thema heute in der szene zurück
[Musik]
phoenix runde
meine kollegen und ich sind heute hier
nach kiew gekommen mit einer klaren
botschaft
die ukraine gehört zur europäischen
familie
ein meilenstein auf ihrem voraussetzung
reichen europäischen weg ist der status
eines beitrittskandidaten
darüber beraten die mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union in den nächsten tagen
wir wissen es braucht einstimmigkeit
unter den 27 eu-ländern
beim europäischen rat werde ich mich für
eine einheitliche haltung staat machen
deutschland ist für eine positive
entscheidung zugunsten der ukraine
soweit also der bundeskanzler heute
nachmittag in kiew gemeinsam mit den
anderen staats und regierungschefs
sprechen wir über diese reise mit diesen
gästen herzlich willkommen ihnen
herzlich willkommen moritz gathmann
chefreporter bei cicero viele jahre
korrespondent in russland und er
berichtete zu kriegsbeginn auch aus der
ukraine herzlich willkommen albrecht von
lucke jurist und politologe redakteur
der politischen monatszeitschrift
blätter für deutsche und internationale
politik in kiew begrüße ich jetzt genia
bälle who setzt sie ist ukrainische
fotografin und künstlerin und lebt
abwechselnd in kiew in und in berlin und
sie vertritt die allianz ukrainische
organisationen herzlich willkommen und
ihnen auch herzlich willkommen lars
haider chefredakteur des hamburger
abendblattes und auto einer autor einer
biografie über olaf scholz
gehen wir jetzt erstmal nach ihr fragen
wir dort viele rositz heute dieser lang
ersehnte besuch des bundeskanzlers
direkt auch dann mit seinen europäischen
kollegen wie ist diese reise angekommen
in der ukraine
danke dir die frage und die und für die
einladung an der sendung teilnehmen
ja es ist keine leichte zeit gerade
jetzt in der ukraine heute ist 113 dann
des krieges eller es laufen sehr sehr
harter kampf im osten des landes und die
laune
allgemeine laune im lande ihr sehr stark
mit mit diesen ereignissen verbunden mit
den menschen in ost und trotzdem dieser
besuch war unglaublich wichtig und man
hat in diesem besuch viel erwartet in
erster linie hat man waffen begangen
erwartet
neue besprechungen unmöglichkeiten und
dann klar auch eine äußerung über move
alfred der upd ukraine und ich finde es
klingt sehr optimistisch was herr scholz
uns versprochen hat wenn dieses besuches
bedeutet europäische union
ja versteht diese zur ist situation der
ukraine und deutschland äußert sich klar
für den status des kandidaten es ist
eine symbolische gäste und ist sehr
wichtig heute und hier aber eine
symbolische geste sagen sie und die
waffen sind ja halt eben da wurde eben
nicht das zugeständnis gemacht was
präsident selensky eigentlich gefordert
hat herr van look wie haben sie das
empfunden heute diesen besuch als eine
enorme diskrepanz in der tat die
beitritts
zugehörigkeit bzw die chance und die
aussicht eu mitglied zu werden dass eine
bloße aussicht erklärung die übrigens
auch wir haben hier den ton von scholz
gehört mit einem solchen
erwartungsmanagement auch wieder
zurückgenommen oder beziehungsweise
relativiert oder ein langer langer weg
war der symbolische akt aber wenn man
sich bewusst macht und die kollegin hat
es ja geschildert die brutal die lage in
der ukraine ist gegenwärtig dann war die
fa die differenz papieren zu der
eigentlichen forderung die schon vom
nächsten tag an wieder lauter werden
wird wo bleiben die waffen wo bleibt die
militärische unterstützung und insofern
glaube ich dass was wir heute erlebt
haben als eine ja auch von präsident
elends die sehr dankbar aufgenommen eine
geste der drei
staatslenker übrigens alles
westeuropäische lenker dass man herrn
johannes noch mitgenommen hat war
ausdrücklich eine geste an osteuropäer
um nicht gewissermaßen zu sagen als die
drei kollegen aus dem gründungs länder
der der iaa
begründung sondern aber eben doch eine
absolute westig ab was ja durchaus zu
recht kritisiert wurde warum nicht davor
das weimarer dreieck dass diese drei
gewissermaßen als die 3,3 klasse während
in polen dabei holen dabei gewesen als
ein großer richtige chance wäre nicht
obendrein noch italien ag ist ich will
damit sagen man hat große verheißung
gemacht übrigens makro und italien noch
weit mehr aber ich glaube dass bericht
sich ungemein mit der harten realität
und schon morgen wird die enttäuschung
sehr schnell wird die enttäuschung sehr
stark wieder da sein weil die
waffenlieferung die eigentlich gebraucht
denn natürlich nicht in dem maße
gekommen wie sie eigentlich erwartet man
bleiben wir mal bei dem eu-beitritt
status also wie wichtig war das dass das
heute versprochen wurde weiß ja nur eine
aussicht ist weil dieser prozess wird ja
lange dauern und erst mal muss sich die
eu ja auch einige das ist ein wichtiger
punkt da auch wirklich hinweisen
natürlich war johannes dabei aus
osteuropa aus dem neuen eu ländern aber
es gibt natürlich auch nach herrn orban
aus ungarn der die sache ganz anders
sieht und ich hoffe dass diese
geschlossenheit die da heute
demonstriert wurde dass die auch am
nächsten donnerstag und freitag zu sehen
ist wenn tatsächlich die eu-chefs
darüber entscheiden werden ob die
ukraine und auch moldawien übrigens
einen wald status bekommen aber
natürlich war das für die ukraine
psychologisch sehr wichtig jetzt dass
sie diese klare ansage auch in kiew von
diesen drei sehr wichtigen staatschefs
bekommen dass sie eben dazu gehören das
tatsächlich war auch eine ganz
frankreich hat sich erst nicht so
positiv geäußert also frankreich muss
ich sagen man hat mehr überrascht als
stolz sagen wir es mal so auch mit
seiner position zur eu aber auch mit
seiner äußerung dass man der ukraine bei
stehen werde bis zum sieg das ist ja
eine andere anlage als wir von scholz
gehört haben
wir haben ein scholz eben gesehen dass
wirkte sehr trocken eigentlich haben sie
das den eindruck dass dieser besuch
jetzt der auf dem man so lange gewartet
hat dass das dazu doch beigetragen hat
diese verstimmungen zu lösen ich denke
ich denke schon dass es gelöst gelohnt
hat dass er so lange gewartet hat auch
also dass meine sieht man stelle sich
vor die wenn alle ganz am anfang da
hingefahren und jetzt werden die calima
das würde gar nicht dass wir ein zweiter
oder dritter besuch gab es war schon ein
starkes signal heute man sieht es auch
daran dass russland ja gerade jetzt die
gaslieferung reduziert das kommt ja
nicht von ungefähr weil die sich
offensichtlich ärgern dass die europäer
so ein geschlossenes signal zeigen ja
und stolz das ist ich kenne ihn ja sehr
sehr lange es ist immer wieder ein
phänomen zu sehen dass ihnen egal was
passiert dass er sich nicht anmerken
lässt dass ihn das irgendwie berührt das
wäre so ein moment gewesen wenn man da
kann man sich ja anmerken lassen da kann
man vielleicht auch mal ich weiß ja dass
man den trainer im auge haben muss ob
man könnte sich diese emotionen anmerken
lassen das ist aber sein oberstes
prinzip ja sich nie zu keinem zeitpunkt
emotion an märkten das ist schwierig
weil er wirkt kann oftmals in so einer
situation teilnahmslos und fast so ein
bisschen komisch hast du ein bisschen
komisch ich sehe schon
fast ein bisschen komisch wenn er in
solcher situation dann auch vom blatt
stocken vom blatt abliest oder das passt
irgendwie mich ja aber es ist mehr es
ist mehr wenn man sich den ton und die
ansage von scholz vergleichen mit dem
von makro- und draghi anschaut dann
waren es ein ganz bewusst und nicht nur
seiner fehlenden emotionalität
geschuldete zurückhaltung ein absolut
erwartungsmanagement draghi wie makro
hamm dezidiert gesagt mit der ukraine
wird die freiheit europas verteidigt man
kaum eine gewaltige pathetische rede
weil er auch genau wusste was er davor
für ukraine über die ukraine gesagt hat
man darf
putin nicht demütigen eine ungeheure
aussage vor dem hintergrund dass tag für
tag und das hatte den ski dann ja auch
als reflex gesagt jeden tag die ukraine
ukrainer mit hunderten von toten
gedemütigt werden er hat das pathetisch
so überhöht er hat sich also ungemein
weit aus dem fenster gelehnt wer unter
scholz sehr bewusst glaube ich die
versprechungen nicht in dem maße gemacht
hat das wird übrigens auch nicht nur
positiv ankommen ich glaube man wird
wahrgenommen haben dass er nicht gesagt
hat und dass hier ein ganz
entscheidender punkt dem die ukraine ich
meine zu recht davon überzeugt ist dass
sie die freiheit europas tatsächlich
verteidigt insofern als sie die kräfte
putins bindet sie ist die der staat der
dafür sorgt dass putin nicht zu anderem
in der lage ist hat schuld sich dazu
nicht eingelassen und das war er nicht
nur empathisch seiner qual seiner
emotionalität aufnehmen und sie hat
gesehen das war auch glaube ich sehr
bewusst er wollte sich da nicht
einlassen ich würde gerne auch frau
besetzt wie wichtig war es für die
ukraine das besonders dass scholz hat
einfach das so ausdrückt dass er sagt
die ukraine gehört zur europäischen
familie also wie sehr hat man an scholz
andere erwartungen als er die anderen
ich denke die ukraine wartet schon seit
beginn des krieges dieser verzögerungen
von waffenlieferungen von der seite
deutschlands und das ist eigentlich in
tallinn mission ready weil diese
verzögerungen bedeuten für uns für die
menschen hier auch eine position von von
der ganzen euro raum von deutschland
gegenüber dem kriege ging über den
sterben ein versteck praktisch das ist
einverstanden sein dass hier täglich das
land menschen und das leben kommen hohe
see ruiniert werden und ja man erwartet
eigens nicht handeln man erfahre handeln
von der seite durch und aber jetzt zu
sagen wir dieses versprechen dass man
sich für den eu-beitritt
einsetzt das hilft ihnen doch im moment
gar nicht oder was wie kann das das
kriegsgeschehen beeinflussen
das ist unglaublich eigentlich denke ich
auch weil
wir sehen dass für russland eu beitritt
und nachbarn sind eigentlich letzte zeit
bedeute keinen unterschied
und diese gäste ukraine den
kandidatenstatus zugeben es ist
eigentlich eine eine sehr deutliche
erster gegen gegen dean bis man politik
gegen die idee dass man gut ins gesicht
treten muss weil das ist eigentlich das
zerbrechen seines gesichts weil weil
putin es muss sehr stark in
symbolen politik denkt in symbolen h
also versteht praktisch nur oder
meistens die sprache polen ja wir wollen
uns und das ist ein sehr klares symbol
des ukraine zur europäischen familie
gehört
von der seite der europäischen ländern
okay also das wichtig er vergab man
wirklich daran anschließend auch noch
mal darauf hinweisen dass mitri mit wwf
der frühere russische präsident
und heute chef des sicherheitsrates der
äußerst sicherheits immer auf telegramm
sehr explizit hat er sich schon beruf
gemacht der hat heute auf telegramm noch
mal die frage aufgeworfen ob es die
ukraine überhaupt in zwei jahren noch
geben werde und dahingehend würde ich
schon sagen natürlich wenn die eu die eu
sagt die ukraine bekommt einen
mitgliedsstatus in dieser situation
das ist natürlich ein klares statement
gegen diese russische art zu sagen
gibt es die ukraine noch gibt es sie
vielleicht nur noch als rumpf start da
in der west ukraine den rest holen wir
uns also dahingehend ist diese richtung
putin ist es ein wichtiges zeichen
es wurde ja auch selent g eingeladen zum
nato gipfel nach
madrid wo er sagt da könnte er sogar
vielleicht selber hinfahren also wie
wichtig ist dass das dann auch die nato
sozusagen dieses ihn umarmt sozusagen
also die eu ist in dieser situation
mindestens so wichtig wie die nato ich
würde sagen die nato ist eigentlich noch
wichtiger weil die nato am ende
in einer kriegssituation die kraft ist
die auch militär lieferungen
organisieren kann es gab ja diese nato
treffen gestern wieder das da ist mir
die äußerungen des us
verteidigungsministers in erinnerung
geblieben er hat gesagt wir werden auch
weiterhin himmel und erde in bewegung
setzen um der ukraine zu helfen
dass das das sind wichtige punkte gerade
von der nato das sind sich auch aussagen
die ich mir auch von scholz tatsächlich
gewünscht hätte in den letzten monaten
die auch eine ganz andere wirkung
entfaltet hätten als das lavieren das
ist man eben von scholz gesehen hat über
die letzten monate und das eben die
ukraine so frustriert hat und nicht nur
das rhetorische lavieren sondern eben
auch das lavieren in den taten aber sie
haben ja gesagt hat das ist schon war
gut dass er jetzt erst gefahren ist weil
er jetzt eben auch was
eben mitbringen also konnte jetzt was
mitbringen ist es ja es kommt ja dass
unsere phase wo man das gefühl hat der
krieg wird in den staaten die die
ukraine unterstützen ein bisschen
vergessen das ist nicht mehr das
hauptthema in den staaten und jetzt noch
mal so ein impuls zu setzen etwas
mitzubringen nämlich den die eu den
eu-beitritt auch der versprechen von
waffen bei den werften ist immer das
problem also ich verfolgt dass ja auch
die diskussion so richtig weiß man ja
gar nicht also hat deutschland jetzt
waffen geliefert liefert deutschland
waffen in welchem umfang das ist das was
mich stört dass olaf scholz nicht
einfach mal klar sagt das haben wir
schon gemacht und das können wir nicht
machen und warum können wir das nicht
machen weil wir die eskalation nicht
wollen oder was ja noch viel schlimmer
sein könnte und was jetzt gerade im
russischen staatsfernsehen glaube ich
gestern thematisiert wurde die haben ja
gar nichts mehr die haben eigentlich
alles was sie hatten was halbwegs zur
verfügung war das haben die ukraine
geschickt und mir haben sie also ist er
als ausreichend halt sagt er man kann
dann bei der bundeswehr geändert werden
bevor wir zu den waffen kommen noch mal
einen einen nachsatz nochmal eine
nachfrage noch mal ganz kurz zur eu er
von lukas ist denn wenn das nicht
funktioniert also wenn jetzt auf einmal
ungarn sagt wir sind da nicht für oder
wenn auf irgendwelchen anderen gründen
und der untergrund der prozess ist ja
lang dauert ja sehr lange ich sowieso
endlos deswegen ich finde es interessant
was man sagt oder ist ja was dran die
garantie dass man ein eu-mitglied ins b
ins auge fasst ist eine bestandsgarantie
allerdings in grenzen keiner kann sagen
wie groß die ukraine nämlich noch ist in
dem augenblick wo irgendwann sie dann
teil bin aber es ist natürlich schon so
ist wäre ein absoluter frau und ich
halte es für ein totales scheitern der
diplomatie wenn die großen drei die nun
da waren in kiew am nächsten donnerstag
ist es glaube ich eine absage von
hannover an erfahren würden das kann ich
mir beim besten willen nicht vorstellen
dass die eu jetzt noch abschlägig in
diesem punkt entscheidet das müsste sich
auch erst meine damalige einig ja aber
es geht hier um mehr es geht hier um
hergeben indizierung ist geht hier um
die gruppierung der drei starken
westlichen mächte und ich vermute auch
dass das durchaus nicht so ganz aus
heiterem himmel organisiert unseres
absprachen gab die dass die davon
ausgehen lassen das klappt das dann auch
den wert her problem setzt bitte
verstehe ich es richtig dass jetzt
gesagt wurde wir wissen nicht wie groß
ist oder sein ja also das ist eine sehr
große hinterfragung der ganzen
ukrainischen strategie über eigene
integrität über über eigene grenzen zu
denken als die die wirklich bestehen
sollen und diese option als temporär zu
betrachten wir müssen nicht vergessen
dass die opposition ist es ist wirklich
etwas sehr archaisches und es bedeutet
nicht dass es bestimmte direktoren
gesetzt werden also es muss deutschland
wird nicht vergesst alles bedeutet nicht
weniger dort zum beispiel in der
diskussion über die waffen in
deutschland in deutschen medien wird sie
oft gesagt in bremen muss zum beispiel
beginnen diese
verhandlungen diplomatische
verhandlungen und vielleicht eine
frontlinie muss ein flieger und man wird
man wird ja man wird es wird immer
unterstrichen dass so die menschenleben
gerettet werden aber in den besetzten
gebieten und blockt dort weiter sind
sehr also unversichert es gibt ja es
gibt vor verhaftungen und die menschen
sterben die ganze zeit also
frontlinie einzufrieren
und das bedeutet weniger waffen in die
ukraine es bedeutet überhaupt nicht
menschenleben zu retten das ist sehr
wichtig nie zu vergessen
ja ok klarer klarer punkt dass wir weil
der krieg ein bisschen in den
hintergrund gedrängt wurde und
vielleicht wollte ich dazu sagen das war
nicht mein punkt ich wollte das noch mal
erklären ich befürchte bloß und darum
wird es in den nächsten wochen gehen ich
befürchte und das ist doch die große
frage ob die westlichen staaten die sich
heute so stark eingelassen haben auch
makro noch weiter gehen und gesagt hat
eigentlich wollen wir die ukraine voll
und in ihrem ganzen territorium
verteidigen
ob die westlichen staaten wirklich dem
rechnung tragen und am ende die mit
ukraine ist militärisch so stark
verteidigen dass sie in der lage ist und
darauf wollen sie ja hinaus dass sie
sogar das ganze territorium wieder eines
tages hat glücklicherweise der krieg
daran habe ich leider das befürchte ich
ich teile die einstellung dass das
eigentlich zu verteidigen ist aber ich
habe große zweifel ob das gelingen wird
weil ich nicht den eindruck habe dass
diesen großen worten heute schon an den
nächsten tagen die taten tagen taten
folgen die da lauten beliefern dann auch
die waffen um drei jahren genau der
punkt warum funktioniert es nicht merkt
man was es hat man hat ja ganz klar aus
der ukraine bedarf angemeldet der nicht
erfüllt wird also
da ist die enttäuschung vorprogrammiert
ja
natürlich die ukraine in gewisser weise
pokert sie auch immer sehr hoch also man
meldet einen sehr hohen bedarf an man
weiß dass man diesen hohen bedarf dann
am ende auch nicht nicht bekommen wird
aber
wahrscheinlich denken man je höher man
poker desto mehr bekommt man am ende
auch
aber unabhängig davon welche strategie
die ukraine verfolgt sie braucht
natürlich insbesondere artillerie
auch inzwischen immer mehr westliche
artillerie westlicher bauart weil die
munition für die artillerie sowjetischer
bauart zu ende geht und es auch keinen
nachschub dafür gibt
und warum funktioniert es nicht ja das
ist eine gute frage
die europäer tun sich offenbar immer
noch schwerer mit diesen
waffenlieferungen etwas gesagt gemeinsam
mit großbritannien und usa und
deutschland soll es halt eben da mit der
initiative geben dass es mehr 8er ihre
waffen gibt genau das ist abgesprochen
aber das betrifft nur eine bestimmte art
der akademie oder die mehrfach
raketenwerfer rheingold ich weiß ja
genau meine hoffnung ist da ehrlich
gesagt dass großbritannien und die usa
da diese lücke füllen das hat man ja
auch bis jetzt auch gesehen bei den
waffenlieferungen die die europa
restlichen die eu-mitglieder einfach
nicht leisten können
das ist aber mehr eine große schwäche
wir müssen uns doch ich finde das muss
man doch auch ernsten den mond gesetzt
man muss es mal deutlich formulieren
helsa lenski sagt das und ich finde mit
einer gewissen moralischen berechtigung
erfragt sich im jüngsten zeit -interview
großes interview fragt er sich und das
habe ich bei der kollegin auch aus
gehört diese anfrage wie kann es
eigentlich ein sein dass ein land wie
die bundesrepublik die vielleicht mit
ihrer bundeswehr blank ist die aber in
ihrem eigenen land die größten
rüstungsschmieden der welt hat nicht in
der lage ist in einer solchen situation
den bei start oder fast nachbarstaat
ukraine mit den waffen zu helfen die sie
kaufen da weise oder sonstiger weise zu
lieber in der lage war das ist die große
anfrage und auf die hat herr scholz
heute keinerlei antworten noch im
interview was für ihn sagen sagt ihr
habt wir tun das notwendige das ist doch
natürlich in den augen der ukraine eine
farce jetzt muss ein bisschen
frühstücken wir hören denn es kommen nur
drei mehrfach raketenwerfer nutzer aus
deutschland die hat stimmt aber die
kommen doch nicht machen wie wir kommen
aus den usa
4 ich glaube aus den usa ist entsetzlich
sagte den letzten sieben aus den usa
kommt 4 oder frankreich kommen drei also
so zu tun als ob deutschland in dem fall
eine sonderrolle hätte ist halt falle ja
aber das war es also mit verlaub linke
die mehrfach erklärt er war wirklich
aber dann reden sie über die dinger aber
sie reden nicht über die tatsache dass
die usa in einem ganz anderen maße die
ukraine und den usa wer gar keine
unterstützung der ukraine denkbar dass
heißt und das ist doch das grundproblem
ich habe übrigens frankreich und italien
gar nicht aus wir müssen darüber einfach
feststellen und das ist das dilemma der
ukraine wir leben in westeuropa in einer
völlig anderen situation der osten
europas und darum geht es im kern der
osten europa lebt einer kriegssituation
das ist übrigens nicht nur die ukraine
die baltischen staaten nehmen sich als
genauso gefährdet war herr putin vor
zwei tagen sagte in einem zynismus
sondergleichen peter der große hat vor
200 jahren nicht schweden überfallen hat
russische er dem 21 jährigen in 21
kriegsjahren zurückgeholt und in dieser
situation befinden wir uns heute auch
wir holen russische erde zurück dann
empfinden dass die litauer die ersten
die balten empfinden das in gänze
genauso als eine kriegs anfrage das ist
die lage in osteuropa und der westen
europas und das geht immer weiter gen
süden und westen noch nimmt es zu ist im
gleichen maße in dem er abstand zu
rostock hat empfindet er sich nicht als
kriegspartei so noch als einen kontinent
im krieg sondern als ein kontinent
frieden und dieses thema hat hat scholz
heute auch in keinster weise irgendwie
dem land erklärt das nie dem land das
wir in einer gewissen weise als europäer
und solidarisch begreifen müssen als ein
kontinent der in gänze sich mit den
ausgeruhten lehrern da kriegst du das
unbegründet nicht statt und das muss man
in aller schärfe auch sagen hey was
würden sie denn sagen was ist das
hindernis mehr waffen zu liefern ist es
wirklich ein politisches oder ist es ein
ja einmal die hölle ist das einfach
nicht mehr das gleiche urteil ich kann
nicht beurteilen wie viele waffen
tatsächlich in deutschland zumindest im
bundeswehr bestand sondern
offensichtlich gar überhaupt selig ist
da ist es da ist es da schwierig
ansonsten hat scholz natürlich immer
versucht immer alle dinge im blick zu
haben also diese angst dass das ganze
eskaliert er hat ja nicht umsonst
gesprochen von einem atomkrieg hat nicht
umsonst von der angst waren drin welt
gesprochen und das ehrlich gesagt dass
die usa mehr hilft beim ich glaube etat
verteilungs etat die usa von 800
millionen euro im jahr ist klarheit als
deutscher und amerikaner leben auf einem
anderen
leben hier in der eu bei ich will noch
einmal ich glaube es gibt wirklich auch
die pop jetzt können ob ihr gehört doch
wer ist da kann ich ja die sind jetzt
anlässlich des expand ist leider im
moment ein mit sinnvoll die gesinnten
welt die konzerne bieten ihre waren ihre
panzer an die sambier und wir müssen uns
schon bewusst machen es gibt diese
politische bot man kann sich darüber
streiten um so richtig ist aber es gibt
ersichtlich nicht die politische
bereitschaft der bundesregierung zu
sagen wir kommen den anfragen der
ukraine aber nicht eintreten die
verfolgung auf ferien
endlich sein wo man jetzt gut als
hauptargument das ganze ganz schön aber
das aber damit ist ganz entscheidend ist
historisch betrachtet schon fast die
atomare angst die angst vor der atomaren
bedrohung war am anfang ja richtig das
kann man ja nachvollziehen aber in dem
augenblick wo putin land gewinnt umland
gewinnt und die angst davor dass er
gedemütigt wurde und als verlierer in
russland die nötigung erleiden würde
dass er die atomwaffen würde einsetzen
müssen ist gegenwärtig in nichts zu
spüren er werde jetzt kann uns kann die
franzosen die italiener die die
deutschen als spaghetti
heißt es hier mit frisch frecher und uns
und kartoffelpresse bestimmten und sagen
wir lachten bereich damit will ich sagen
diese angst vor der atomaren bedrohung
die am anfang das kann ich verstehen
weil die deutschen in der regierung dem
eigenen volk vor diesen sie war da aber
es ist gegenwärtig mit händen nicht
zugreifen kann sagen genau das ist eine
völlig andere zeiten jetzt frau belarus
it was die ecke biegt man in der ukraine
darauf dass halt eben deutschlands nicht
mehr liefert deutschland sagt aber auf
der anderen seite machen das klavier
liefern wir unterstützen ganz starke
unterstützen wir auf anderen feldern
also was erwarten sie da genau und
was wir ja was erwarten sie das problem
ist dass man spricht ja oft über das
dilemma der ukraine oder unterstützung
der ukraine aber in wirklichkeit es geht
und die destabilisierung der ganzen
europa gelagert dieser krieg dauert die
lenker ukraine kann desto länger gibt es
den krieg in mitteleuropa desto länger
bedeutet das dass so eine vernichtung
von menschen erreichte dieser art
überhaupt möglich ist man bombardiert
spritze könnt ihr das überhaupt
vorstellen es ist schwer vorzustellen
das ist wie ein albtraum aber das ist
zerlegt und je länger das dauert er
länger dass man erlaubt und praktisch
mit dieser verzögerungen erlaubt man das
desto mehr und gründlicher wird unsere
gemeinsame welt destabilisiert und
deutschland bis zivilisiert auch und
deutschland in eine gefahr gesetzt
destabilisiert zu werden weil russland
verstehen dass alles als ein lautes ganz
europa zu terrorisieren nicht nur
mitmachen lieferung nicht nötig nicht
nur mit bombardierungen und krieg
sondern auch mit zb
wissen getreide krise und weiter einfach
man sagen
dass jetzt auch das reduzieren der
gaslieferungen zum beispiel also all
diese sachen da reagiert russlands ja
dann drauf hat man wenn man jetzt aber
schaut wenn jetzt gesagt wird oder oder
wie vans oder ist es eine politische
entscheidung von stolz dass er so
handelt oder halt eben doch die sache
wir haben dann nicht mehr die bundeswehr
ist kaputt gespart hatte da können wir
ihnen liebe
ich würde ich beobachte das ja seit
anfang dieses krieges ich habe den
anfang des kriegs in der ukraine auch
erlebt raketenbeschuss und so weiter
ich habe den eindruck dahinter steht
tatsächlich auch so eine german angst
es steht dahinter diese alte
westdeutsche position bei den krisen
dieser welt doch lieber am rand zu
stehen sich nicht zu weit einzumischen
am ende macht man noch was falsch
irgendwie doch in verhandlungen immer
mit zu machen er der vermittler zu sein
als in einer krise zu führen
dahingehend möchte ich auch noch mal auf
den zeitpunkt des besuchs zurückgeben
sie sagen richtig jetzt war vielleicht
der richtige zeitpunkt des besuchs weil
er tatsächlich etwas substanzielles
mitbringen konnte es war aber erst der
richtige zeitpunkt des besuchs weil er
in einem zeitfenster am anfang den
richtigen zeitpunkt verpasst hat als
nämlich boris johnson auch nach kiew
gefahren ist und ich würde sagen in
diesem zeitfenster wäre es sehr wichtig
gewesen für olaf scholz auch nach kiew
zu fahren und zu führen in dieser eu zu
führen das zu tun wofür offenbar
deutschland bis heute angst hat nicht
darauf zu warten dass die amerikaner
oder die dritten uns wieder raus hauen
sondern zu sagen wir sind ein riesiges
industrieland wir sind großer was und
produzent wir müssen uns da jetzt ein
wir gehen das risiko ein und vereine
haben wir auch eine historische man darf
auch 1 nicht unterschätzen man hat ja
immer gesagt makro wird dann gemeinsam
mit scholz fahren der osten der ukraine
natürlich die polen auch neben
deutschland noch und nicht zu unrecht in
einer anderen verpflichtung war es ist
doch kein zufall erster sind wir näher
dran wir haben aber auch eine besondere
geschichte gegenüber der ukraine nämlich
die große sorge team ist schneider der
große historiker bringt das immer wieder
zum ausdruck die große sorge deutschland
und russland würden sich gemeinsam über
die ukraine hinweg einigen obwohl sie
beide eine imperiale geschichte haben
nämlich die kornkammer der ukraine
sowohl der nationalismus wie auch der
kommunismus erhaben und sich aneignen
das ist ein riesiges verantwortungs
problem was dahinter steckt also dieses
dilemma immer ungemein pathetisch dann
auch wieder die lehren aus der
geschichte in stellung gebracht zu haben
hat uns natürlich genau in dieser
bereinigung rede von selensky die frage
eingebracht was ist jetzt eure lehre aus
dem nie wieder was soll jetzt einer sei
auch bei der rede von scholz am 27
februar das gefühl hatte jetzt
eigentlich als mode von das ist das
dilemma bei scholz bis heute ist das
gefühl er ist auf der höhe der
ereignisse auch dann wenigstens zu
erklären auch die dilemmata meinetwegen
zu erkennen am anfang hätte er die
lämmer zum teil erklären können es hat
aber endlos gedauert und gegenwärtig hat
man auch nicht den eindruck sehr
deutlich sagt
wir haben begriffen dass hier etwas
verteidigt wird auch wenn er und das
glaube ich muss man schon auch wieder in
rechnung stellen ich glaube richtung
belarus ich glaub sie sind fast zu
optimistisch es ist viel brutaler in
deutschland und im westen wird generell
und das ist ja die große angst der
ukraine wird die wahrnehmung eher
getätigt wenn wir einen frieden finden
mit russland unter preisgabe gewisser
gebiete der ukraine
dann ist der frieden und dann ist der
einstand wieder hergestellt das ist
immer die sorge der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer gewesen und ich glaube der ist
mit dem heutigen die sorge ist in
heutigen tage überhaupt nicht ausgeräumt
die betreiber existiert nach haider was
glaubt ihr denn moldawien genau dieses
kleine land das nicht nahtlos an die
daten status haben bekommen ja aber ich
meine die sind noch viel kleiner ist die
ukraine wenn die russen die angreifen
die sind tatsächlich innerhalb von zwei
oder drei tagen erobert also er hat er
glauben sie dass die tatsache dass
scholz heute sich die zerstörungen
angeschaut hat das er dann wirklich da
war dass das etwas was ich am anfang
sagt er mit anderen augen auf diesen
krieg
er weiß ja was war passiert ist ich
glaube er braucht jetzt nicht denn da zu
sein und sagen oh das ist ja alles viel
schlimmer als es von den bildern kommt
ich glaube er weiß sehr genau was da
passiert und er weiß auch sehr genau um
die verantwortung die erde hat er hat
glaube dieses natürlich das problem dass
einerseits nicht erklären kann das ist
ja wir haben am anfang der des krieges
haben wir alle gefordert olaf scholz
muss mehr kommunizieren da hat er ja
interviews gegeben ein bisschen zum
kinderradio und also interview es wurde
dadurch nicht besser also es ist
eigentlich besser je mehr sagt er desto
weniger habe ich nicht verstanden und
das ist das problem das wir hier über
viele dinge reden und versuchen scholz
zu deuten weil er uns offen sich nicht
erklären kann was er für eine politik
macht das ist immer schon sein problem
gewesen in der vergangenheit hat er
meistens gute politik gemacht man hat
sie aber trotzdem nicht verstanden das
ist aber in so einem moment natürlich
fatal weil man den eindruck bekommt er
führt nicht weil man den eindruck
bekommen deutschland tut nichts und er
sagt immer ich mache alles was ich mache
und in große abstimmung hat
offensichtlich auch große scheu davor
etwas zu machen was die anderen nicht
machen würde hätte ich auch angst davor
vorzupreschen
weil er hat auch verfügung versprochen
ja nur in diesem moment muss man
verstehen was versteht olaf scholz
unterführung ich glaube dass das dass er
denkt dabei schon sie er ist dass er
sagt ich habe doch alles gesagt in
meiner rede im bundestag was wollt ihr
denn ich habe doch die politik in diesem
lande 100 milliarden 2 muss nicht alles
auch den ich hab's doch radikal
verändert und mit dieser rede war für
ihn eigentlich alles gesagt gaddafi
liefern unternehmen und dann macht er
sich ganz arbeiten er denkt man
natürlich so und wann geht es denn los
und das ist das wo ich glaube die
kommunikation dieses kannst das ist und
bleibt das allergrößte problem man
konnte nicht ahnen dass so eine so eine
situation kommt in der kommunikation
entscheidend ist und es ist vielleicht
jetzt tatsächlich besser die
kommunikation robert habeck und annalena
baerbock zu ein bisschen zu der frage
aber es ist ja auch schwierig mit seiner
eigenen partei und der fraktion das ist
ja nicht eine kommunikation ja aber im
moment ich habe im moment spielt das
keine rolle im moment ist es ist die
partei sie erstaunlich ruhig also finde
ich die spd spielt keine rolle das
problem ist nicht die art und weise
wieder spüre ich würde gerne auf den
punkt schauen weil jetzt alle sagen man
muss ja dann auch verhandeln muss ja
auch gucken wie man wie es weiter geht
und da gab es eben auch einsatz von olaf
scholz der gesagt hat es kann kein
diktat frieden geben frau bloß wie
wichtig ist das oder wie groß ist die
angst haben wir so rum wie groß ist die
angst in der ukraine das von außen
sozusagen gesagt wird wie es gehen soll
wie ein waffenstillstand unter welchen
bedingungen ein frieden geschlossen
werden soll
denke es ist keine ukrainische an und
ich versuche das immer wieder zu sagen
in dieser runde es ist keine klinische
an sondern er soll eine europäische bank
sein ich finde ich euch höre ich denke
wird schon hat immer noch eine illusion
dass wenn man zum beispiel premier stück
der rektorin an russland ab füttert wie
du bist an sich erst einmal zu beruhigen
und es wird eine hohe sicherheit für
eine weile entstehen dafür aber gibt es
überhaupt keine garantie und das äußert
sich also russisches propagandistischen
russische maschine der propaganda muss
er sich die ganze zeit entgegen zum
beispiel man hört wir werden in berlin
habe man auf russischen fernsehen aber
niemand anscheinend in deutschland
nehmen das ernst man hat auch das
versprechen mit panzern archivs so gerne
nicht ernst genommen und jetzt haben wir
diese versuche übernachtet deswegen ich
würde eigentlich ein wenig rational das
sehen entweder gewinnen wir diesen krieg
in dem wir eigentlich eine einheit eine
rechts situation in europa wieder schafe
und diesmal leider nur mit gewalt weil
andere sprache versteht adresse nicht
oder hier alle sind in gleicher absolut
gleicher ärmeren länder wie die ukraine
und viel reichere und mächtigere mit
deutschland wir sind ihr alle in
gleicher situation einer tiefen
unsicherheit wann wann bewacht wann wann
wäre denn
dann würden sie sagen
wann hat die ukraine den krieg gewonnen
trainer hat mich wenn ich zeitlich
sondern genauer
ukraine hat diesen krieg gewonnen wenn
die grenzen der ukraine gesichert sehen
wann russland als aggressor ihre taten
anerkannt hat und andere prozesse
innerhalb russland auch laufen wo wir
perspektive sehen einen normalen nachbar
zu haben ich möchte nicht jetzt in
einzelheiten eingehen aber das
wichtigste ist unsere grenzen sind
gesichert und nicht die grenzen von
23 februar sollen die grenzen vor 2014
also mit der krim das heißt ja ja weil
wahlkrimi war gewalttätig robert und
creme ist ein ja eher erster 40 in
diesem sarg von otto realen eroberungen
wo menschen menschenrecht der
europäische werte einfach verschwinden
herr gartmann wir ehrlich zu ihr ich
finde ja ja ich würde gerne gartmann
dazu gehören ein bisschen auf die zeit
auch nur noch zehn minuten haben also
wie wie kann das funktionieren es gibt
keinen diktat frieden heute wurde es
mehrfach betont dass nur die ukraine
sagen kann wie es ausgehen soll aber die
ukraine braucht die eu braucht die nato
all das also ist die das was man der
ukraine so zusichert ist das eigentlich
ehrlich
also ich ganz kurz noch hinzufügen die
das angebot des seelands g vor einigen
wochen schon gemacht hat an russland ist
ja dass man erst mal zum status 23
februar zurückkehrt
in verhandlungen mit russland also im
prinzip hat sie lenski schon eine
kompromiss- forderung einen kompromiss
erst mal angeboten und das signalisiert
er natürlich auch dass das signal sendet
er auch an den westen dass er sagt klar
auf lange sicht hin wollen wir unsere
territoriale integrität wieder
herstellen aber wir sind auch bereit in
verhandlungen mit russland erstmals zum
status quo 23 februar zurückzukehren
aber er hat ja jetzt noch mal gesagt
dass man auch dann über die krim
nachdenken sollte
das ist staatsräson kein keine
ukrainischer präsident der die krim
abschreiben würde würde er noch im amt
bleiben natürlich ist die teil der der
ukraine aber das ist schritt 28 würde
ich sagen nach vielen vielen anderen
schritten die die ukraine gehen muss und
inwiefern das ehrlich ist von seiten des
westens diese diese unterstützung
zuzusichern ich glaube was der westen
tun kann ist die ukraine politisch
militärisch und wirtschaftlich
so zu stützen dass sie tatsächlich
diesen ukrainischen all diesen
russischen angriff stand halten kann ich
glaube nicht dass er sein scheitern weil
es über lange zeit ja wir sprechen hier
auch nicht über die nächsten wochen oder
die nächsten monate dass das ist eine
lange zeit es wird nicht möglich sein
die russen jetzt alle militärisch aus
dem land zu werfen aber auf dem
schlachtfeld werden die bedingungen
geschaffen mit denen man dann in
verhandlungen gehen kann und da muss die
ukraine stark genug sein um auch
entsprechende forderungen stellen zu
können in verhandlungen mit russland von
lobbyist wie sie empfinden sie das kann
gehen wenn man sagt es gibt kein diktat
frieden ukraine soll das alles selber
entscheiden kann sie das wirklich na ja
das ist ja auch eine vergiftete
äußerungen was heißt sie kann alles
selber entscheidend entscheidend ist wie
weit sie dabei unterstützt wird das wird
dabei ja nicht mit gesagt natürlich und
das haar ausdrücklich übrigens noch viel
mehr mag roma com hat heute dieses wort
ja sehr stark gebraucht weil die sorge
hinter makro vor allem war dass er in
gemeinsamen gesprächen mit wladimir
putin implizit eine verhandlung über die
köpfe der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
hinweg führen würde das war die sorge
auch nach seinen jüngsten äußerungen man
darf putin nicht demütigen hat sich
heute also enorm davon distanziert dass
er quasi friedensverhandlungen über die
köpfe hinweg führt aber ja was heißt das
denn wir können nicht gegen die ukraine
entscheiden die fähigkeit der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer frei zu
entscheiden und zu sagen jetzt sind wir
bereit friedensverhandlungen wirklich zu
führen hängt natürlich maßgeblich davon
ab wie weit sie unterstützt werden und
das ist dann damit gleich ob er der
entscheidende faktor also die frage der
militärischen unterstützung wird auch
mit darüber entscheiden wie weit und wie
viel sie verlieren und insofern kommt
diese diese ganzen aussagen des heutigen
tages werden die nächsten tage und
wochen ungemein auf die waagschale
gelegt werden und die werden zum schwur
kommt an dem augenblick wo man sieht ob
die ukraine in der lage ist sich
wirklich zu verteidigen und dann werden
die ganzen aussagen die groß vor allem
makro war ja viel viel pathetische das
muss man stolz wieder was zu gute halten
also er hat sich beileibe nicht
ungeheuerlich draghi war recht sachlich
aber im ton auch näher beim accord fast
manchmal obwohl die italiener noch
zurückhaltend da sind ja die italiener
sind aber auch gesagt luca ihnen muss
den frieden wählen den sie haben fällt
ja ja das ist ein so schönes wort müssen
sich mal bewusst machen sie muss den
frieden wählen den sie haben will die
ukraine wird und das ist die brutalität
sie wird gar nicht wählen können wenn
sie nicht hinreichend unterstützt
deswegen sind all diese aussagen das ist
in das freie ermessen der ukraine
gestellt eine eine hoch prekäre aussage
denn sie werden nur dann frei wählen
können wenn sie irgendwie in der lage
sind augenhöhe bzw verteidigungs fähig
zu sein und das weiß das war ich
übrigens auch putin das infame bei der
ganzen geschichte ist doch folgendes
putin weiß doch ganz genau wie er den
westen in seinem friedens denken vor
sich her treibt er macht es jetzt
mittels des gases wir haben jetzt schon
die sorge dass wir kein gas mehr
bekommen er macht es mit der inflation
er macht es übrigens auch mit dem er den
weg des zerstörten erde zerstört die
ukraine immer weiter er weiß wenn ich
den krieg weiter wird dann wird es eines
tages westeuropa aufbauen müssen
deswegen sind zum beispiel die
portugiesen gar nicht sonderlich der
news darüber die ukraine in die eu
aufzunehmen weil das kostet uns alle
viele da noch mal drauf genau auf die
auf das wie man ja wie putin darauf
reagiert oder herr haider wie würden
sich sagen wie wichtig ist es aus
deutscher sicht dass man sozusagen das
verhältnis mit russland immer so klar im
blick hat das würde uns ja auch sehr als
deutsche vorgeworfen dass es zu nah ist
dass man hat eben putin nicht demütigen
sollte das sagte makler also dass wer
war der ist da der richtige umgang mit
schon daran denken dass russland bleibt
also egal was passiert russland ist
bleibt und eines tages wird man sich
wenn auch die ukraine und die russen
sich an einen verhandlungstisch setzen
müssen erst einmal und danach wird es
aber irgendeine art von zusammenarbeit
zusammen kommt man kann sich jetzt nicht
vorstellen und man wird ja irgendwie mit
diesen russen auskommen müssen wenn wir
nicht in eine zeit da kommen wir was
komplett installiert ist und
deutschland stellt sich jetzt dafür auf
deutschland stellt sich dafür auf einer
art und weise weil sie gesagt hatten man
man man sieht sie gefahr nicht doch ich
meine olaf scholz hat gesagt wir bauen
in den nächsten jahren eher jahrzehnten
die stärkste armee die es in europa gibt
also das hat deutschland schon
verstanden nur wir haben sich in den
vergangenen fast könnte man sagen 16
jahren zu dem ganzen thema gar nichts
gemacht haben da gedacht dass so etwas
nie wieder passiert und wir stellen uns
darauf ein er oder sie wollten da
widersprechen
muss leider sagen wir ja weil man
betrachtet wie
man man sagt wesselmann mein putin und
man bekannt dass die wette wie eine
absolute stimmt und man denkt nicht dass
mit verlieren des krieges eine diktatur
autoritäre diktatur gesteckt wird und
wahrscheinlich wird das ein ganz anderes
land sein mit dem wir verhandeln werden
und warum muss europa für alles zahlen
weil russlands stück für stück ukraine
zerstört warum muss man nicht russland
zum zahlen zwingen eigentlich warum
diese funktion werden wir gar nicht
gesprochen
das wundert mich sehr und das bedeutet
man betrachtet als eine sehr stille ein
sehr stabiles system das eigentlich
nichts des bildes jetzt sogar in dieser
sendung vor allem scheinen auf der seite
der listen des rechts zu sein der
menschenrechte zu sein das wundert mich
hat man diese wieso sollte man dann
darum gehen mit russland wie sehr ist
russland denn jetzt auch wirklich
geschwächt dass es vielleicht dann auch
ein einlenken gibt also können diese
sanktionen auch vielleicht den krieg
beenden also ich glaube den ersten
wochen und nach den ersten harten
sanktionen gegenüber russland gab es bei
einigen etwas zu großen wunsch glauben
dass jetzt dass putins regime
zusammenbrechen wird unter diesen
westlichen druck das hat sich leider
nicht erfüllt dieser dieser wunsch
glauben
mein eindruck ist dass dieses regime
auch jetzt noch sehr stabil ist dass wir
auch in den nächsten jahren noch mit
putin zu tun haben werden diese ganzen
dieses gerede über die palastrevolution
im kreml oder brieflich krankheit viele
auf eine leere bindungen zu russland
also da auch das spüren sie dass das
ganz von unterstützung gibt für putin ja
natürlich gibt das ganze unterstützung
besonders bei der älteren generation und
solang solange russland nicht
wirtschaftlich komplett abschmiert und
das ist momentan noch nicht zu sehen das
könnte sich ändern in ein zwei jahren
das tatsächlich auch bei der breiten
bevölkerung
der niedergang spürbar ist der
wirtschaftliche niedergang aber solange
das nicht passiert ist dieses land doch
relativ stabil das heißt es ist
natürlich richtig man muss davon
ausgehen dass man mit denen noch zu tun
haben wird aber das darf nicht heißen
dass wir
ihn gewähren dass wir putin gewähren uns
bedingungen zu stellen wir müssen uns
maximal bemühen uns unabhängig zu machen
von diesem regime damit es uns nicht
mehr erpressen kann weder die mittel
noch mit sonst was auf dem weg ist man
ja auch wie wichtig ist dann auch so ein
zeichen also dass der heute eben hier
regierungschef aus der eu stehen also
ist das was das haben die fans schon
wahrgenommen wird ist das ein punkt wo
der westen sozusagen noch mal ja sich
anders positionieren sollte gegen
russland der ewige traum großteils ist
natürlich immer die eu zu schwächen sie
zu spalten auch die eu und die usa
auseinander zu treiben den westen
auseinander zu treiben wenn es
tatsächlich gelingt die geschlossenheit
so zu zeigen wie heute und die
aufzuhalten auch bei dem
regierungschef treffen der eu in der
nächsten woche dann ist das schon ein
wichtiges signal richtung moskau aber
natürlich werden die immer versuchen
solche aktionen zu entdecken und zu
vertiefen stichwort orban stichwort
österreich ja also da muss die eu einmal
geschlossen ja ich würde die letzten
sekunden gerne nochmal nach kiew den pro
velo roses wenn sie was ist was ist
etwas was sie hoffen lässt
ich hoffe dass eigentlich ukraine
viel schneller als man denkt und europa
und usa
irland sich immer wieder mit den
christen und haben sich schon mehrmals
die ihr am anfang wenn sie zum beispiel
eingeschätzt haben wir schnell ukraine
erobert wird deswegen in meine hoffnung
ist dass eigentlich wir viel schneller
eine rechts situation in der ukraine
schaffen werden nicht in lauffen und
nächsten ein paar jahren weil so lange
putins regime existiert soll danke wird
er versuchen europa zu den kriegen zu
destabilisieren und leider läuft dieser
krieg gerade auf den chronischen wunden
und die ukraine wird zerstört und wenn
wir zulassen dass es mehrere jahre
dauert dann jetzt noch vielleicht ein
weiteres land zerstört und ich hoffe es
wird alles nicht passieren und ukraine
wird es nicht zulassen zusammen mit den
fahrern zusammen mit der europa und mit
der starken starken gemeinschaft die
eigentlich auch existiert ganz
herzlichen dank ihnen nachher wir
wünschen ihnen alles gute und
dass sie so gut durch die zeit kommen
und das wirklich bald ein frieden
herrscht in der ukraine danke ihnen
danke herr gartmann hervorlocken danke
ihnen fürs zuschauen bei uns geht es
weiter mit phoenix der tag und da sehen
sie natürlich die ganze pressekonferenz
auch nochmal ausführlich und durch die
sendung führt meine kollegin konstanzer
bratzke bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]